y
[Música]
imágenes que nos llegan desde dubai la
ciudad más grande y famosa de los
emiratos árabes unidos- recibiendo el
año
2022 con estos rascacielos imponentes en
la ciudad de dubai tamos pasó a nuestros
titulares
antes de año nuevo dejará de funcionar
en alemania tres de las seis plantas
nucleares aún existentes en el país el
gobierno se convertirá en el primero del
mundo en completar la transición en 2022
continúa la emergencia ambiental en
colorado eeuu las autoridades informaron
que cerca de 1.000 casas fueron
afectadas por los devastadores incendios
que azotan el estado el presidente joe
biden aprobó una declaración de desastre
para la zona
la presidencia de sudáfrica considera
que los peores momentos desde la
aparición de omicron ya pasaron se
levantaron algunas de restricciones y
bajó la presión al sistema de salud
bienvenidos a este informativo con el
resumen de las noticias más importantes
del mundo en este último día del 2021 mi
nombre es daniel hablando ahora
iniciamos con noticias que nos llegan
desde alemania hoy se apagan
definitivamente tres de las seis plantas
nucleares que hay en el país
las centrales de brock dorff emsland y
ground en el norte de la nación europea
verán el fin de sus operaciones antes de
la llegada del año nuevo y las tres
restantes seguirán el mismo camino a
finales de 2022
la medida convertirá a los alemanes en
pioneros en abandonar la energía atómica
actualmente las fuentes renovables
representan el 50 por ciento de la
canasta energética alemana
el proceso de desmantelamiento lleva
tiempo porque también hay muchas
cuestiones de seguridad a considerar si
el trabajo va bien podemos comenzar a
desmantelar a partir del 2023
y luego la mayor parte la eliminación de
los componentes radioactivos también se
completará pronto pero pasarán varias
décadas antes de que el edificio sea
visible
y el medio ambiente y el cambio
climático siguen representando uno de
los principales desafíos de la humanidad
la ong ambientalista greenpeace se
presentó en vísperas del inicio de un
nuevo año un balance del 2021 y los
retos para el próximo año para ello
conectamos en argentina con bruno
giambelluca coordinador de la campaña
del clima y energía de greenpeace señor
bruno gracias por acompañarnos y le
pregunta primero cuáles son las
principales conclusiones de este informe
bueno las principales conclusiones son
que estamos viviendo una crisis
climática sin precedentes hay ejemplos
de esto digamos inundaciones aumento del
nivel del mar
pérdida de biodiversidad deforestación
necesitamos digamos tomar acciones
concretas particularmente los países que
se comprometen al acuerdo de parís
aumentar esas ambiciones para reducir
las los gases de efecto invernadero y
así poder ir controlando la situación
ambiental que tenemos tanto en argentina
como en el resto del mundo bueno y
hablemos ahora justamente de esas tareas
pendientes de la comunidad internacional
para luchar contra la crisis climática
que podemos hacer de ahora en adelante
bueno la última cumbre de naciones
unidas que se desarrolló en glasgow
escocia dejó sabor a poco en una cumbre
en la que se tenía mucha expectativa
había sido suspendida por el commit 19
pero lamentablemente las ambiciones de
los países fueron digamos muy bajas
necesitamos aumentar esas ambiciones los
países tienen que entender que se vive
una realidad digamos grave
ustedes bien decían que hay desastres en
colorado en diferentes partes del mundo
y esos desastres digamos son
consecuencia de la crisis de
biodiversidad y climática que vivimos
hay que actuar cuanto antes si lo que
queremos es un futuro digamos sostenible
para las generaciones que vienen ustedes
muchas gracias será por una gran peluca
coordinador de la campaña del clima y
energía de greenpeace y seguimos
hablando del clima esta vez en eeuu y es
que en el estado de colorado ya son
cerca de 1000 los hogares afectados por
los devastadores incendios que han
golpeado la zona según las autoridades
aún no se ha podido establecer cuál fue
el origen de la conflagración que
gracias al viento se propagó rápidamente
por el condado asimismo los servicios de
energía o de emergencia mejor informaron
que aún no se reportan víctimas fatales
el presidente joe biden aprobó una
declaración de desastre
este fue un juego rápido con ráfagas de
hasta 105 millas por hora saltando
instantáneamente sobre carreteras y
vecindarios
los residentes quieren regresar a sus
hogares lo antes posible para evaluar
los daños en muchos de estos vecindarios
que actualmente están bloqueados todavía
es demasiado peligroso regresar charter
luisa y el ministro de la presidencia de
sudáfrica mondo lee woon google dio a
conocer que posiblemente ya pasó lo peor
de la más reciente ola de contagios de
kobe de 19 del país africano el
representante del órgano ejecutivo
informó además que se levantarán algunas
restricciones y que omicron ya no es una
carga tan grande para la salud pública
sudáfrica dice que su cuarta ola puede
haber pasado los nuevos datos muestran
que las infecciones por coronavirus se
redujeron la semana pasada en casi un
30% en comparación con la anterior
mientras que los ingresos hospitalarios
disminuyeron en 8 de las 9 provincias a
mediados de diciembre con el aumento de
la variante omicron el país llegó a
tener unos 26.000 casos diarios
según los expertos omicron ha alcanzado
el punto álgido con manifestaciones
clínicas que no han provocado ninguna
alarma en la situación hospitalaria
y las condiciones permiten que se
levante el toque de queda el anuncio
llegó justo el último día del año al
tiempo que las autoridades han eliminado
la restricción de movimiento de
medianoche y han vuelto a permitir la
venta de alcohol una hora antes se
limitan además las reuniones a mil
personas en interiores y a 2000 al
exterior aunque sólo se ha registrado un
leve aumento de muertes durante el pico
de omicron se mantiene la obligación de
llevar mascarilla en los espacios
públicos la nueva variante del crono
virus se identificó por primera vez a
fines de noviembre en sudáfrica y
botsuana ahora está presente en más de
100 países
seguimos en china que aplica medidas
severas en el marco de su programa que
ha denominado cero tolerancia contra el
hobbit 19 la ciudad de xian se mantiene
bajo un estricto aislamiento pese a
quejas de desabastecimiento por parte de
los habitantes en la última jornada la
ciudad registró 195 nuevos casos de
contagio
humillación pública para quienes atentan
en contra de la política de 'cero cobit
del país
estos son cuatro hombres vestidos con
trajes de bioseguridad esposados y
fuertemente custodiados los acusan de
llevar ilegalmente a extranjeros a las
fronteras de china que han estado
prácticamente cerradas desde marzo de
2020 la policía local les colgó del
cuello carteles con su nombre y foto y
los hizo desfilar por la ciudad los
medios estatales criticaron estas
acciones asegurando que están prohibidas
desde 1980 pero la pandemia ha hecho que
las medidas draconianas sean algo común
en china xian ha visto como sus 13
millones de habitantes han sido
encerrados durante una semana los
hogares reciben comida de manos del
estado cada tres días algo que es
insuficiente para muchos que han tenido
que recurrir a las redes sociales para
buscar ayuda
[Aplausos]
qué es lo que tienes que comer me muero
de hambre
no tengo nada nada las autoridades
locales admitieron que la entrega de
alimentos se ha visto afectada por
restricciones mientras priorizan las
pruebas masivas 160.000 personas se
movilizaron y se construyó un enorme
centro de pruebas nuevo de autocuidado
tenemos la capacidad para procesar 2
millones de pruebas pcr todos los días
con nuestro propio método y ha
proyectado el resultado un número de
casos diarios que es sólo una fracción
de lo que se puede encontrar en otros
países el jueves sólo 224 personas
dieron positivo en el territorio
continental cuando se trata del cob y de
en china parecería que el fin justifica
los medios
y para despedir este informativo
volvemos con las imágenes que nos
llegaron previamente desde dubai la
ciudad más grande y famosa de emiratos
árabes unidos- y como la ciudadanía en
esta ciudad despide el 2021 y le da la
bienvenida al 2022 vemos el burj khalifa
que es una torre de 830 metros de alto
que domina este paisaje lleno de
rascacielos en dubai emiratos árabes
unidos- una de las ciudades que ya le
dieron la bienvenida al 2022 como
también lo hicieron otras en australia
[Música]
así finalizamos esta emisión en francés
24 quédense con nosotros